okay so I'm I'm super happy to be here
today to tell you about the story of our
company I'm going to start off with a
flashy announcement that we had in
December of last year when we got a 60
million dollar Grant from the graph
foundation and for the rest of this
class I'll explain to you what what it
means to get a 60 million Grant and how
we did it and I'm going to try to
emphasize some of the aspects of what
we're doing that I think are going to be
enduring features or enduring needs of
the space
um yeah so this is a this is a timeline
of our company
and we have three threads in the
evolution of our company
and below the evolution or below the
timeline I also have the price of
ethereum and the reason that I have that
there is to emphasize my opinion that I
think a lot of what has happened for our
company uh we comes down to being in the
right place at the right time and having
the right preparation and also I think
networking is super important
um so that's yeah so this kind of gives
you an idea of why things were happening
to us when when they were
so
we were founded in February of 2020 and
our initial Focus was on fully
homomorphic encryption
we had four co-founders Ahmet Oz can he
is our CEO he's I'm at would you mind
raising your hand uh so Ahmet has a PhD
in physics he spent the first part of
his career doing silicon research for
for IBM and then he transitioned into
machine learning and he went to IBM
research and he led the machine
intelligence Department
um
I uh Aaron introduced me and
um
and then uh Dr gokai seldomli he is a
cryptographer he's right there
uh Gokey and I are academic Brothers we
have the same PhD advisor our our
advisor started the largest
cryptographic engineering conference
it's called Chez and gokai has spent his
whole his whole career focused on
cryptography and cryptographic
engineering gokai is gokai was
previously at San Jose State University
and prior to that he was at Samsung and
at Samsung he designed all of the the
cryptographic hardware accelerators for
Samsung's SIM cards so gokai has
millions of cryptographic Hardware
accelerators deployed
and then our fourth co-founder is Alexi
assamin Lexi sitting over there
Alexi is our lead developer he has a
background in device physics and he uh
he also made a transition into machine
learning and he worked with Ahmet at IBM
research where he he was the lead
architect on a system that had around
over a thousand fpgas and they used they
built this machine to do evolutionary
algorithms so you can
uh you can see that our team has a mix
of AI and cryptography and that's that's
been the theme of our story from the
beginning and uh to now
our initial Focus was on on encrypted
computing
we specifically we focused on fully
homomorphic encryption which allows you
to to do uh computations uh directly on
encrypted data and our beachhead Market
was machine learning as a service
so we were going to do ml specifically
we're going to do ml inference on the
cloud
and our competitive Advantage was
algorithmic and Hardware acceleration
so I have a question at this point is
anybody in here a cryptographer or
focused on cryptography in your studies
everybody
okay so then what you may not know is
that okay so something interesting is
that fhe is that was actually created or
made practical by a PhD student here at
Stanford fairly recently I think around
2014 2013. it was done by Craig Gentry
who is a PhD student of Dan Bonnet and
Professor Bonet will be is a professor
here and he'll be speaking next week so
not only is he an awesome presenter and
teacher but he also is has made tons of
contributions in the field of
cryptography everything I'm going to be
talking about today he has influenced
um
so our initial so here's a use case to
help you understand the use of of fhe
fully homomorphic encryption
and we built this we built this use case
out for demos so imagine you have a
smart watch and it can record your
heartbeat data you can encrypt that
heartbeat data locally on your watch you
can then send that encrypted data to the
cloud and on the cloud even if people
wanted to hack or see the data they
can't see the data but using fhe on the
cloud we're able to run a deep neural
network to predict whether the heartbeat
is normal or abnormal and then you send
the encrypted everything's encrypted you
send the encrypted result back to the
user where they decrypt it and we were
able to get this this whole thing
running in about 1.3 seconds and that's
versus the off the shelf tools which
would take about a minute so we were
able to do this fully homomorphic
encryption in real time and if you've
heard has anybody heard of fhe before
this class okay
quite a few people yeah so anytime you
hear about fhe you hear that it's not
practical it's interesting but it's not
practical it is practical for some
applications
in addition to these uh these use cases
that we proved out we were also working
on algorithmic accelerations this comes
from gokai's uh gokai's previous
research during his PhD we we designed a
new NTT algorithm NTT is the is a
Fourier transform for integers
and we were able to run our our NTT so
NTT is needed for fully homomorphic
encryption you need to use it over and
over again when you're multiplying two
encrypted numbers
and so you want to make it as fast as
possible and if you look at the table
you can see our results on the right
hand column that's uh that's the latency
to multiply two numbers in microseconds
and we were we were able to get a lot
faster uh speeds than other people in
Industry including multiple results from
Microsoft
this work on fhe was allowed us to get
seed funding from the NSF so NSF has
funding called sbir it's for small
businesses and it's non-diluted funding
it doesn't have a lot of overhead it's
usually a small amount of money but it's
really useful when you're when you're a
small company
we were also used so our fhe work also
allowed uh Ahmet and I to get
fellowships from activate activate is a
deep Tech startup that's run out of
Berkeley lab and they give you two years
of salary and they give you travel money
and if this is a really good program
especially if you're into if you're
doing a deep Tech or hard tech company I
highly recommend checking out the the
activate Fellowship they also don't take
any equity and they don't have any
requirements from you
so we did fhe for about a year we were
we were funded uh personally funded so
sorry we were self-funded we didn't have
any VC money and we throughout that year
we developed our Tech but we weren't
able to get any Market traction we were
targeting beachhead markets of either
fintech or Healthcare neither of those
domains care care about Cutting Edge
cryptography why because those domains
make decisions based on regulations and
fhe isn't regulated so it doesn't help
them at all
luckily around that time you could see
that the crypto was taking off and we
were introduced to the graph protocol
and the graph it turned out they had
needs that were 100 overlap with our
skill set so we we applied for a wave
one Grant with the graph and we started
working with them initially in uh in
Automation and optimization
I'm going to introduce the graph in a
moment but I'm going to motivate it by
digging down into the weeds a bit with
ethereum so ethereum does everybody in
the in the class know that ethereum is
actually a distributed computer
and and that all of the validators on
our ethereum are all running the same
program anytime a transaction is
submitted every validator in ethereum
has to run this program so it's very
expensive to run transactions on
ethereum
um
uh so etherscan etherscan.com is like a
debugger for ethereum and you can go
there if you ever make a ethereum
transaction you can go here and you can
look it up and you can see exactly what
happened and if you dig down under the
hood this is what all your transactions
look like they're just Blobs of they're
just binary blobs
um ethereum gets about a million of
these things per day and the role of
ethereum is only to provide security the
thing all this distributed computer
their only job is to say okay I have a
new transaction in let me update the
state of the of the computer is it valid
yes that's great if not it rejects the
transaction the role of ethereum is not
to tell you what the state of the
machine was a year ago or five years ago
it's not tracking it's not it's not
tracking that it's only like it's like a
computer uh on your desk the job of your
computer on your desk isn't to tell you
it's state a year ago it's to tell you
the state now applications can tell you
the state of your of certain aspects of
your computer a year ago and that's what
the graph does its job is to tell us the
the state of the system in the past or
if we want to do more processing
post-processing of the transactions that
are that are done on ethereum the graph
can do that for us
so the graph the graph's mission is to
index all blockchains the protocol
itself runs on ethereum currently but
the workers in the protocol are watching
all of blockchains and the graph as you
as many of you know it provides an open
API and this is basically it basically
makes it so anybody who's building
applications can have an easier time of
getting data that they want for websites
or or some other higher level
applications
it's also permissionless which means
that anybody can use the graph without
applying you don't have to sign eulas
you know like if you've ever written a
mic an apple uh app you have to go
through all sorts of Hoops to get access
to their SDK you don't have to do that
with the graph you can just you can just
start using it it's also Geo distributed
and censorship resistant and it's used
by all of the major applications in
ethereum and across many other
blockchains
so here's an example of it being used
uniswap is a decentralized Exchange
and it is the largest application in
crypto in blockchain outside of Bitcoin
so ethereum and all other ethereum-like
chains ethereum uh uniswap is the
biggest if you go to
info.uniswap.org you can see information
about this exchange and if you were to
click on the developer pre the developer
settings for this webpage you can see
that all of the data that it's that it's
displaying so this data is like total
value locked into these smart contracts
how much volume is is sent through these
exchange all of this data is coming from
the graph so the graph is serving the
graph is where you're when you're
looking at crypto applications you're
good you're typically getting data from
the graph
the graph has is is also a decentralized
protocol
this means that it's all it's all run by
individuals and small businesses it's
there's no centralized organization that
controls this this protocol
there are six different roles in the
graph protocol and the two most
important ones are consumers and
indexers consumers are the people who
want to query data for their for their
applications and index surge sell the
data or they provide the data
so now I'm going to transition into what
semiotic is doing in the graph we do we
we specialize in two things still we're
still doing AI type work and
cryptography work on the AI type work we
specialize in simulation and
optimization
so the the graph because it's
decentralized it has to incentivize
people to run and operate the graph so
there are all these complex incentive
mechanisms to to get people to do the
roles that we need done so that the the
protocol operates
and the awesome thing about crypto is
that most of the projects are open
source
and so here we have the graph all the
code is open source it's actually a
really large economy and you can
containerize this thing and you can
simulate the entire economy and once you
can simulate this thing you can then
start asking what-if questions with your
simulations and then you can use these
simulations to guide changes to the
mechanisms of the protocol
so in addition once you have the ability
to simulate you can start doing more
interesting things like training
reinforcement learning agents and I'm
going to step I'm going to walk through
a case study where we train pricing or
agents to compete over pricing in the
protocol
Okay so
in the in the graph we basically have if
you want to boil down what the graph is
it's a query Market
people have data for sale and people
want to buy data
and the people who are selling data are
called indexers and there are many
indexers currently there are about 200
indexers
and all of these indexers are competing
to be able to provide the best service
and they compete they compete how do you
define best service well it could be
latency it could be uptime it could be
the data freshness and it could be price
and price has a big plays a big part in
the competition and then on the other
side of the query Market you have
consumers and of course they want to
spend as little as possible further
further data
so we wanted to provide automated agents
for the indexers so that they can learn
how to adjust their prices so they're
making as much revenue as possible
and we have currently done that we used
we used reinforcement learning and
trained uh deployed some online agents
and we have agents that are currently in
beta and what you see here on the x-axis
is time and on the y-axis we have
revenue and so you can see that this
agent what this agent is doing is it's
learning to adjust its query prices over
time such that its revenue is increasing
on on this topic we're going to be
presenting at Devcon as does it who is
going to Devcon in the in the room
C1
two just one
okay a couple a couple people are going
to Defcon so this is ethereum's main
conference
and if you want to come up to speed with
what's going on in crypto and if you
want to really like accelerate uh like
uh you're learning and you're networking
Devcon is is an awesome conference to go
to it's going to be in Bogota next week
um before before I leave this slide I
also want to I want to point out that
within the graph protocol we have we
have an economics working group and we
have phds that in operations research
optimization robotics Ai and we're all
working on we're all working on many
problems Beyond just this so This the
protocol is very complex there are many
interesting problems and if you're in
economics or if you're in optimization
or any of these other fields then this
is a this is a great area we we believe
this is a great area to do to do work
and and also get publication uh where
the results out of
so now I'm going to transition into our
cryptography efforts
um
and I'm going to focus on I'll be
focused on verifiable Computing and
verifiable data
specifically I'm going to be talking
about verifiable payments
so the context in the graph is at any
time someone is buying queries or yeah
asking for queries they have to sign a
receipt saying that they're willing to
pay for those queries
and then it's the job of indexers to
collect all of all those receipts and
then submit them for on chain so that
they can get paid
so our goal with verifiable payments was
to prove that all of the signatures were
okay and some of the amounts
so why can we not simply have buyers
data buyers submit an on-chain
transaction
and have the data sellers submit their
data on chain
and response
there are a couple reasons does anybody
can anybody tell me
that's right I mean it'd be too much
data it would be incredibly expensive
all parties would go bankrupt that day
um so what we want is what we would
prefer is to do all of our computations
off chain and we want to interact you
always want to interact on chain as
little as possible for cost reasons
so this is exactly what verifiable
Computing lets us do
verifiable Computing is kind of the
superset and then I'm sure many of you
in the many of you have heard about
snarks or ZK snarks
these are these are provable ways to do
computations off chain and what happens
is you have a worker who we call
approver do the original work that we
want done and while they're doing the
work they create a proof they then
submit the result and the the proof to
the ethereum virtual machine to to they
submitted on chain and then on chain the
work or the proof can be checked cheaper
than it would have been for the on-chain
uh for the evm to do all of the
computations to begin with
so it's cheaper to check the proof than
it was to do the work to begin with and
this allows us to push this this field
of verifiable computing ZK snarks allows
us to push computations off chain
um so this is another area that uh
that's going to be it's going to
continue to it's really hot right now
um and it's going to be actually here at
Stanford you have you have an advantage
of being here because there's a lot of
techniques coming out of Stanford
related to the field of verifiable
computing again Professor Bonet is
leading uh in in this area as well
okay so in summary for this section
we're currently developing a snark which
enables High throughput payments for the
graph
and this is going to allow indexers to
aggregate what aggregate millions of
receipts in an efficient way
okay
so now this brings brings me to the uh
to the core developer Grant I'm going to
give you a few more uh details about
that
so the grant is was non-dilutive
it it lasts for eight years so you can
think of this as like a temporary Aqua
hire
um it allowed us to grow to 10 people
this year
and the next year it's going to uh it's
going to fund us to grow to 15.
everything that we're doing is open
source which is great for the employees
because they can they can have artifacts
of their efforts
and uh the company semiotic is also free
to expand into other business units
which we have
the so this may be the first time that
you've heard of some of a structure like
this or something being built like this
so I'm going to spend a few minutes just
explaining the organization of what's
going on here
um Okay so the all of the work in the
graph protocol is managed by What's
called the graph foundation so we have
the graph Foundation at the top
and then
below that we have seven different core
Dev teams and each of the core Dev teams
have similar grants to semiotic
and we all coordinate with each other
everybody has their own specialty Edge
node they created the protocol to begin
with
extremely fast they have technology to
index very quickly
figment has a lot of devops expertise
they're really big in the staking
community
Masari is well known for their data
processing abilities The Guild
specializes in graphql
which is not related to the graph
graphql is like a database query type
language
graph Ops they specialize in graph rated
the graph related Technologies and
infrastructure
so we all bring our our different skills
and we work together to build the graph
so now I get to I'm coming to the the
last thread and the most recent thread
of the company
um like I said we are free to create new
business units and decentralized finance
is the first thing that we focused on
so I'm going to focus uh I'm going to
focus actually our work is focused on a
particular aspect of D5 and that's
related to dex's or decentralized
exchanges
so
a a decentralized exchange is a smart
contract
and what happens
is that we have liquidity providers who
deposit tokens into the smart contract
the smart contract is just another name
for a program
so liquidity providers deposit liquidity
this would be in ethereum this would be
erc20 tokens
into this into the contract and they get
fees in exchange for people doing swaps
with the program
so Traders can now once they're once
there's liquidity available Traders can
come to this program and they can
deposit assets plus their fees into the
program and they can get assets out so
here here I'm showing asset a is
deposited and asset B is removed
okay so a question that you might have
is how do we know
that uh the the exchange rate between
asset a and asset B is correct
especially when in any Market whenever
someone makes a trade they're going to
have price impact so initially let's
assume that asset A and B are balanced
there's they have actually have a
correct ratio
and that as more of asset a is deposited
it becomes more and more available asset
B becomes more and more scarce so its
price goes is going to go up
well it's the job of arbitragers to
watch these dexes and look for Value
Arbitrage and once they see Arbitrage
once they see oh you know A and B are
out of out of uh whack if I were to to
deposit asset B I would be able to get
more of asset a back than I can get in
any other market then arbitragers will
come in and they will rebalance the
pools
uh does anybody know okay so these These
arbitragers are looking at all the other
dexes so why not why not have the decks
watch what the other dexes are doing why
not have if this Stacks why not have
this decks watch all of the competitors
and all the other dexes to figure out
what the fair price should be
it's because that would require extra
logic
it would require many external contract
calls to all the other Dex contracts and
every call you do adds extra cost
and that's going to drive up the price
for for what it would cost to do a trade
and it would actually become it would
become super expensive
um so that's why it's very it's really
clever that unit swap so is actually
vitalik who came up with this idea as
far as I understand uniswap Hayden Adams
instantiated it they were the first ones
to build one of these things it's very
clever that they're having arbitragers
do the work instead of having the smart
contract do the work and having to pay
for those extra instructions
Okay so
in in July of last year we participated
in the East global hackathon
and we we were just curious about the
amount of Arbitrage opportunities across
different chains
so our project is looking at all uniswap
V2 clones so there are many dexes that
are like uniswap we call those uniswap
V2 clones and we were looking at there
are many of them on ethereum and there
are many of them on polygon and there
are many of them on all the other chains
and we wanted to see uh we wanted to see
what was it Arbitrage not just within a
chain across the different dexes but
across all the chains
so we built this we built a hackathon
project called Western gate
and since then we've updated it three
times it's now called odos odoscat the
cross domain Arbitrage tracker you can
see it at otos.xyz and what this project
does is we're watching eight different
chains
and we're measuring approximately 30 35
million paths so 35 million different
Arbitrage combinations
and you can see here in this example
that we've measured a ten thousand
dollar this is from last week we
measured a ten thousand dollar Arbitrage
opportunity across the Binet smart chain
and ethereum and basically what you see
here oh you can't see my mouse I'm sorry
uh what you see here is if you would
have put in ustc into BSC and swap
through these through these different
swaps and if you would have put in
ethereum uh on a sorry eth onto ethereum
this much eth and gone to ustc that you
would end up with more ustc
than you started with
so we became really interested in
Arbitrage measurement and and how to
yeah how to accurately measure or
estimate the best paths and this led us
to coming up with a new algorithm uh it
turns out that the same algorithm you
want for this is an algorithm that you
want for swapping doing optimal swaps
so we have we came up with a new
algorithm for optimal swapping and we
built a DEX aggregator so we look at all
of the available liquidity sources on a
chain and then we determine what is we
try to determine what is the best route
through dexes so each of these different
colors you can see the legend here each
of these different colors is a different
decks and for large trades what you want
to do when you're trying to trade online
or on chain is you're going to want to
split your trade up to minimize your
price impact
and uh otos odos.xyz it it does that for
you it comes up with a path for you and
it will execute your path to try to
minimize your your price impact on your
trade
so this is our third and final talk that
we have a third and final talk related
to this at Devcon and it's going to be
an overview of automated Market maker
mechanisms
this is another field the field of defy
and the math behind Defy is another area
that is going to be it's going to be
important for many years and actually
this uh this are you in semesters or
quarters
this quarter you have a class it's on
Tuesdays and Thursdays and it's related
to this exact topic so if you're
interested in finance and defy and and
all this stuff it would probably be a
good class to check out
okay
um I'm near the end and this is I I'd
like to share with you some of the the
higher needs that we have uh in general
we're looking for good developers you
don't have to know anything about web3
really if you're passionate about
software development then we'll teach
you everything you need to know about
web3 but in particular we and everybody
else in crypto is looking for rust and
solidity developers if you learn if you
become proficient at rust or solidity
this is your ticket to basically any
crypto company out there they're all
desperate for those those skills
um we're also looking for data
scientists cryptographers reinforcement
learning experts and this these are for
internship positions but we're going to
be hiring from those positions five
full-time next year
and then on the that's for the graph
side of the house on the Odo side we
currently have full-time needs for
business development develop API
development arbitrage strategy and
capture currently we only just measure
Arbitrage we're not capturing any
real-time data services and
infrastructure
optimization I saw some people taking
pictures but if you would like the
slides this is a QR code to the slides
these resources
these resources have been have all had
impact on me
um
and yeah I can recommend everything here
one thing I didn't mention yet was youth
Global youth Global is an awesome
hackathon it happens all over the world
the next time it's going to happen is
actually it's actually starting in
Colombia in a few days but there's going
to be one in November in San Francisco
and often these these crypto projects
they have lots of prize money for uh for
the saxophones I had one of my friends I
think he made like 12K for like a
weekend hackathon just himself so if you
have a team that you can collect I
highly recommend going to the San
Francisco youth Global hackathon in
November
so that's that's all I have and I think
we have time for a few questions if we
want to do that now or we can wait till
Pizza
yeah no
and
thank you in the talk
um I've collecting questions that people
asked ahead of class through the
question form
um so I guess to begin with um I
received a lot of questions around how
the graph has started as a centralized
service and his mic or is migrating to
be a decentralized one
um could you talk a little bit about the
the business reasons for that
um the business justification for that
the technology challenges and then any
other challenges that come with that
yeah I think that may cover 20 of the
questions that were submitted here so
okay
yeah
so when when the graph started uh so the
a lot of this okay so the graph is a
complex system
and adding decentralization uh
decentralization adds uh more
engineering difficulties
so the reason that we were centralized
at the beginning was just to get
something to work
but when we so the graph has a token
related to it called the GRT and that's
what actually incentivizes all
participants and the mission of the
graph is full decentralization
and that was what that was the vision
that was shared when they started the
project
and basically you can't you can't say
that you're going to start a
decentralized protocol
raise raise money through token sales
and then stay just become a monopoly
it it's just like it doesn't match like
you said you're going to do one thing
and then you you don't do it so the
decentralization has been a core
principle for the founders
of the protocol since the beginning
so that's why we're doing it
um
some of the technical challenges well
you know coordination is a challenge we
have seven core Dev teams and
communication imagine communicating and
coordinating the efforts of seven
different companies plus many individual
contributors
so there's extra Communications cost
when you go to decentralization
um
so uh other technical challenges
um
oh
anybody want to give me technical
challenges
and
basically the economics or the protocol
part like the whole decentralization on
ethereum Etc part is a layer on top
right
and so they focus first on proving that
they could have piece of software that
can indeed reliably and consistently
index all the data storage on the
database serve it on graphql Etc and
then
they eventually you know
um built that layer on top that takes
care of incentivizing indexers to run
the software to um
to thank you
um you know to earn money for allocating
so it's literally called allocations to
allocating their Hardware to
um to index for certain depths and also
there's a layer that is taking care of
incentivizing uh each query that those
indexers are serving to customers and
those so that synced also to our effort
with the with the CK starts right for
the payments but all that is a layer on
top of the software that's already
running in the centralized service
so yeah you know that basically they
prove that he can do it they got lots of
funding from various
known uh investors like coinbase and
they could also capture a huge amount of
the market so basically just Crush
everybody else and use the time to build
the decentralization path right yeah
thank you
uh one one thing that I'd like to that
that I think is interesting about
the
decentralization uh commitment to a lot
of crypto protocols including the graph
is think about what's happening
everything is open source
and everything is permissionless which
means that no one I we can't shut
anybody out nobody can shut anybody out
of the graph
if if everybody working on the graph
today were to disappear if anybody
wanted to
start it back up they could just start
the thing back up because all the code
is available
all the rules are in place
and you could just start running it
again can you say that can we say that
about web 2 companies like let's say
some of our favorite web 2 companies
were to disappear what about all their
code that they're that's of course the
idea can be reinstantiated but what
about all the code they built
all right do we do we have anything else
so another question that's coming up
with all the different roles that are
available in the graph in particular for
indexers it seems like the growth of
indexers is pretty critical to the
growth of the ecosystem and so how is
the graph incentivizing
well there's currently we currently
actually have an incentivization program
for bringing indexers into the network I
think we've grown
from about 160 indexers to about 200
right now
and
um
so will you if we if we see needs in the
ecosystem then we'll basically have
incentive programs to try to encourage
more people to come on and in addition
to that as as in the early days it was
very difficult to run indexing software
there's like a lot of devops skills that
were needed and as time goes on we've
automated many of the technical steps
needed to to run indexers
people and
um yeah why don't you go ahead okay so
like if I'm a diap or like a DEX what
incentive do I have for using the graph
sub graph versus creating my
call
yeah so if you're if you're the question
was if I'm if I'm a Dap I want to build
an application on ethereum
why would I use the graph as as opposed
to writing my own indexing uh protocol
well the the answer is is that it's very
tedious to write an indexer from scratch
and it's a Time Savings it's a Time
Savings thing like if if you want to
write it into if you want to specialize
in writing you know indexing
infrastructure
uh which is is not trivial especially
across different chains and and whatnot
uh and that's you know that that just
takes a lot of time but
yeah
that's it yes yes
that's a good question so it's the
question was if it's if it's a lesser
known chain how long might I have to
wait for the graph to come in and start
indexing it and I'm wondering I don't
know maybe can answer this one so we're
actually starting on an incentivized
program in order to bring more chains
into the graph protocol
the current chain we're working on right
now is the genosis chain that is due to
come online at the end of this quarter
beginning of next year for the
decentralized network on the hosted
service there's 21 30 35 chain something
like that the most of the major chains
that you've ever heard of BSC uh
ethereum
any Solana any of those are they're all
available on the hosted service and as
time goes on they will be added to the
decentralized network
I have a question so how fast can the
graph query data so as we know that
sometimes with ft you want to do instant
cells and these prices are very
sensitive with timing so
I mean how fast can the graph how fast
can we index watch the blocks that are
coming in yeah right
because can react to that information
yeah
actually on blockchains you can't be
infinitely fast because there is a
Hardware close to term again
um uh basically there's some kind of a
cheaters the the blog the finality right
uh you gotta wait for a certain number
of blocks to be passed before you can be
sure that a transaction will not revert
um ethereum especially after the merge I
think that was literally two blocks yeah
64. I mean someone remembers the number
uh but
um
so yeah you can go faster you can't go
Infinity fast because basically what's
going on so if we if you think about the
you know back when we had miners uh
miners were you know they were just
doing hashes competing trying to find
magic number that makes a block valid
for the network and basically you can
have at any time at any point in time
multiple
um uh multiple miners that propose a
valid block with a valid magic number
that starts off with all those proposed
blocks would start off from the same
block right and you need a little bit of
time basically for those all those
little branches those Uncle blocks to be
pruned off and be down to a single you
know
strain of you know final chain final
blocks right so indeed you want to be
fast but you can't go in 50 fast so
that's a good thing to remember that's a
little bit weird right with with
blockchains
so maybe if we take that energy if we
take that into account can we answer the
question about the graph
and it's the latency yeah and usually
it's
maybe one or two one or two blocks
usually it's one block Edge one or two
blocks compared to the blocks you would
see let's say on etherscan even on
etherscan you know they wouldn't show
you all the blocks they would add a
little delay also because they don't
know for sure which one of the many
proposed blocks would be the one
uh it also to add to that a little bit
it really depends on the application
that is
that you're querying so there's within
the graph ecosystem there's the concept
of sub graph
the graph is not just an API it is also
an SDK as well you can go onto the graph
today and build a subgraph to index a
particular piece of ethereum say you
wanted all sales events since Genesis to
today you can do that
there are some subgraphs that take
longer to index per block because it
goes through and processes the event
does some data massaging before logging
it into the database
so the answer to that question is it
really depends but again there's a lot
of factors that go into it the slowest
subgraph I've seen takes us up to five
minutes per block that's the EIP 721
subgraph that's your nfts
um some of the faster ones I've seen
block times in the microsecond range so
and that's once the block is finalized
thanks for the answer guys